ja also wenn das bin ich meinen
entführungs level mal nach spüre dann
geht das bei mir um das thema rot rot
grün und zwar nicht so sehr um die frage
haben würde deutschland da schaden ihm
natürlich wird in deutschland schaden
würden wir wirtschaftlich geschwächten
natürlich wird wir geschwächt werden das
ist eine politisch politische frage wenn
es zu dieser koalition kommt wäre das
eine gute sache aber das würde mich
nicht empören das wäre dann halt so die
mehrheit ist gewollt mich empört dass
diese konstellation überhaupt im spiel
fällt in der mitte unserer republik
gehalten oder bei der linkspartei ist
halt nicht irgendeine partei es ist
nicht der sozialisten gruppe aus
stuttgart oder bremen die jetzt mal
skurrile positionen vertreten sondern es
ist die direkte umbenannte sed es ist
die staatstragende partei der ddr es ist
die partei die für hunderttausende
politische gefangene verantwortlich ist
für folterungen die haben die menschen
rücklings an der mauer erschossen sie
haben sie gefoltert und gehen damit
diese partei hat jetzt die chance
deutschland es mir vor allem für
deutschland mitzuregieren und da regt
sich in mir so eine moralische frage ich
finde ist ein verrat an der moralischen
integrität der republik wenn das möglich
wäre
und deswegen ärgert nicht dass das der
olaf scholz ist nicht einfach
ausschließt ich glaube nämlich dass eben
das auf der zielgeraden schade dass
wahrscheinlich das einzige was die
unions wähler mobilisiert das zu
verhindern
und mich ärgert dass deswegen weil es
eine andere kategorie als das praktisch
politische ist nämlich eine frage der
integrität
also ich
vieles spreche natürlich nur ungern dem
hochgeschätzten wolfram weimer der von
der deutschen innenpolitik unendlich
viel mehr versteht als ich trotzdem aufs
vehementesten bringe hier jetzt die
gegenthese ein denn demokratie ist wenn
alle mit allen über alles reden und das
heißt natürlich auch unter umständen
wenn sie demokratisch gewählt sind wenn
sie teil der parlamentarischen mehrheit
ausmachen sind nicht verboten sind ja
dann kommen dann kommen sie denn auch
koalieren und das ist ja etwas was ich
in deutschland auf schweizerische sicht
aber die werden sich die hände verwerfen
gegenstände in meine richtung schmeiß
ich
habe das so ist in deutschland diese
ausgrenze rey ich finde das fürchten
hier habt ihr eine partei deren namen
man gar nicht aussprechen darf sonst
wirst du wohl nicht mehr richtig so ins
land rein gelassen ich spreche enormen
nicht aus ich sage einfach das ist die
lord voldemort partei das ist die lord
voldemort partei in anlehnung an
heribert potter
derjenige dessen namen man nicht
aussprechen auch mit denen reden sie
auch nicht mal in der politik obwohl sie
auch wählen da gibt die deutsche
regierung redet vorher mit den taliban
als sie mit dieser note wohl dem
nordportal redet oder sie findet man so
mit den linken nicht reden und da sage
ich einfach entspannt euch aus meiner
sicht ist deutschland eine gefestigte
demokratie er hat verschiedene parteien
mit unterschiedlichen meinungen gewisse
meinungen finden wir fürchterlich aber
du musst dich hinter demokratie hat auch
mal mit meinungen auseinander setzen die
die nicht passen dass demokratie wenn
alle gleicher meinung sind es keine
demokratie mehr also mit allen sprechen
und am schluss schauen wäre dann
koaliert das ist das ist demokratie aber
diese ausgrenze rey also bitte nicht
aber es hat doch nichts mit ausgrenzen
reiz zu tun wenn man wie völlig richtig
wolfgang weimer sagt dass das was dort
im programm der linkspartei steht raus
aus der nato das kuscheln mit wladimir
putin das nach kuba fahren das
verharmlosen der vergangenheit in der
ddr
die unzähligen opfer dieser
gräueltaten zu verharmlosen dass man
sagt mit so einer partei
darf man nicht reden das ist doch
vollkommen richtig also man sollte
zumindest nicht mit ihnen koalieren als
union und das gleiche gilt doch auch für
die afd ich will nicht dass die cdu dass
die union mit einer partei die zersetzt
ist von rechtsradikalen die man laut
deutsch spricht sogar verschießt nennen
darf die sich aufführt im thüringer
alltag nimmt im thüringer parlament um
im
neonazis auf ihre seite zu bekommen das
finde ich grauenhaft und ich will das
nicht erleben ehrlich gesagt ja es gibt
so viele grauenhaften parteien zum
beispiel nach hinter schweiz da gibt es
auch parteien warum unser haupt
mitnehmen möchte worden es nicht
unbedingt beim abendessen gemeinsam
erwischt werden oder was auch immer aber
am ende haben wir durch die tradition in
der demokratie es sei denn man hat einen
portal begrenzen jakob trend ja
natürlich gibt's auch eine grenze wäre
eine hecke dort stehen und und das sagt
was das sagt dann ist die grenze
erreicht ja natürlich habe ich sage
einmal in der demokratie wenn sie eine
wählerschaft haben jetzt zum beispiel
bei der linken die mir jetzt auch nicht
sonderlich sympathisch ist der andere
auch nicht sieht wenn sie der meinung
sind dass man mit ihnen nicht sprechen
oder nicht koordinieren kann da müssten
sie ja eigentlich aus der demokratie
ausschließt und sagen die dürfen am
parlamentarismus nicht mitmachen das
wäre dann konsequent man mit dem ist ja
immer auch sozusagen eine beleidigung
der wähler verbunden ihr seid eigentlich
gar nicht sagt ist funktionsfähig und
ich war bei allem wider willen den ich
ja nachvollziehen kann und ich will mich
da auch nicht zu stark heimischen diese
in der parlamentarischen deutschen
angelegenheiten aber ich denke einfach
demokratie ist wenn man die offene
debatte die offene auseinandersetzung
sucht und wenn jetzt herr schulz mit der
linken extremen linken koalieren will ja
dann soll es machen dann müssen auch die
cdu bei der nächsten wahl besser
abschneiden und da wieder die macht über
einen bei diesen lakonischen blick
können wir deutschland nicht haben
können wir das vielleicht wirklich und
was ich habe ihn gesehen als die
stimmung in der regel ganz untergegangen
ich hab' ich wollte sie nicht zur
allgemeinen weil das ist an dieses
jahres ist prima und einig die idee für
die liberale bürger demokratie da bin
ich ganz bei ihnen aber mein argument
ist auf einer anderen ebene ist gibt es
so etwas wie eine staats moral ja und
ich bundesrepublik hat eine lügen sie
aus schweizer sicht vielleicht nie so
gut lesen weil wir ja so aber wir haben
sie und das ist das nie wieder dass wir
mit unseren diktaturen sozusagen klare
grenzen gesetzt haben und nun ist das
eben nicht die das gedankengut dieser
diktatur ems ist diese partei wenn sie
heute auf die webseite der linkspartei
gegner klicken sie mal auf ältestenrat
unser geistiges vordenker gremium steht
da wird er gelobt und wer ist der
vorsitzende hans modrow der letzte sed
und staatenlenker der ddr dann gehen sie
ein stück weiter runter wer ist da noch
drin gm kling ein mann der rudolf bahro
mit übelsten gutachten ins isolations
gefängnis in bautzen gebracht hatten
heute genau die gleichen leute was sagen
sie denn dem gefoltert und von bautzen
dass sie sagen ja das ist doch nur eine
frage der politischen liberalität das
ist nicht das ist eine andere kategorie
es geht hier um moral und ich finde
unsere republik die war immer stark auch
weil sie diese moralische integrität
wirklich gewarnt und ich empfinde das
jetzt als ein stück berater nun mal eben
rein du bist ja chefreporterin für
freiheit bei der welt oder ist ja auch
mit tollen ist ja der freiheit spiele
deswegen klingt ich doch gerne mal ein
ja ich muss ganz ehrlich bin dann rein
schwarze kollegen blickte auch immer ein
bisschen ratlos auf die deutsche das
kann ich verstehen obwohl deine
argumente also ich verstehe auch genau
die gegen die linke jeder der schon mal
texte für mich gelesen hat weiß von
meiner nicht sehr großen liebe für die
extreme linke aber ich sehe das auch so
also zwei punkte vielleicht erstens für
würdig aus taktischen gründen natürlich
auch nie ausschließen mit jemanden zu
koalieren also ich finde das macht ganz
den mann hat kein druckmittel mehr als
politischer akteur so warum genau so ein
wenig schließen die ampel aus was hat er
denn davon so dass es da einen punkt und
andere ist wie man meint man kann doch
nicht sagen ich rede nicht mal mit denen
sie sind gewählt diese parteien sind
nicht verboten wenn sie
ganz genau und ich bin absolut der
meinung dass sind findet auch ganz ab
sozusagen
anders bei spieler passt findet genau da
hin wenn es jetzt zu ampel verhandlungen
käme und christian lindner geht in diese
verhandlungen und ist dann der
königsmacher oder eben nicht wenn er
sich weigern würde mitzumachen weil das
müsse nun mit steuerhöhungen gehen oder
so würden glaube ich sehr viel vorwerfen
macht dasselbe wie bei jamaika letztes
mal und sprengt diese noch nicht
vorhandene koalition und würde damit
rot-rot-grün ermöglichen und dann denken
wir wieder das ist ein vorwurf der ist
so illegitime wenn man rot rot grün
nicht will dann muss man entsprechend
wählen und wenn die union oder alle
anderen nicht genug stimmen bekommen und
die die schon dann ist das eben der die
mehrheit des volkes und dann wird so
also ich bin da sehr ich finde das sehr
befremdlich eigenleben so wenn ich noch
einen punkt ergänzen darf ich meine
meine großeltern sind aus deutschland
geflohen die haben alles verloren damals
im krieg die wir kommen mit nicht sind
ich war jetzt so lück meine ganze
kindheit ist nur mit der geschichte des
zweiten weltkriegs und ich meine dieses
trauma vor der diktatur dass man das nie
mehr will das ist völlig klar das ist
auch zu respektieren dass das sicher es
gibt natürlich noch eine andere tendenz
in der politik den missbrauch der
geschichte durch politiker in dem die
natürlich diese trauben und diese
berechtigten sorgen und diese
katastrophen missbrauchen um den
heutigen politischen gegner in einer
ganz extreme weise zu diffamieren weil
das natürlich bequemer ist als sich mit
dem argument aktiv auseinanderzusetzen
ich sage einfach du kannst auch diesen
bestrebungen und auch nicht herr werden
indem es in dem du sie sozusagen unter
quarantäne in den giftschrank stellst du
musst in der politik den gegner immer
wieder legen du musst diese leute
entlassen so wie sie das machen sowohl
rechts wie links du musst sie entlarven
aber du musst mit ihnen reden und wenn
sie gewählt werden ja da jetzt sind sie
teilen
[Musik]